hello hello everybody we are back with more sleeping dogs and being the best undercover cop that Hong Kong has ever seen because how would they know I'm a cop how would they know I'm so good at my job incredibly undercoming all right i had to sleep sleep time hong kong's finest it's okay they can't read english right it's not like hong kong used to be a british colony or anything they won't know i'll just say like we all we all know i'm wearing palest palest by palest the newest designer brand and made in hong kong all right here we go yeah all right so wait what's that my what do i have to do I forgot what my core mission was.
Also, why am I back in this shithole?
I thought I got a promotion.
No, it's Pales by Pales.
It actually is actually an Italian brand.
That's right.
That's why you've never heard of it before.
It's from a very, very small village in Italy.
And it's all the rage in Europe right now.
I know.
You might have not heard of it because you're just not rich enough to realize how expensive this brand is.
uh all right serial killer lead what there's a serial killer right now what the why am i not focusing on that why was i not focusing on that earlier okay what is how do i do the is this serial killer initiation all right you know what no the initiation is much more important so what i'm an undercover cop why the fuck am i investigating a that's a not even my division.
That is not even my division.
I can't believe they're making me do
this case.
I have something more important right now.
Alright, let's go.
Initiation.
I don't remember how to drive, so give me a sec.
Okay.
Alright, that's cool.
Okay, I remember how to drive.
I remember now.
Alright, here we go, go.
How do I turn on the radio?
Here we go.
Oh shit!
I gotta listen to the HKPD radio station.
Oh.
I remember how to turn.
It was like this.
Uh, how do I do like the... How do I...
How do I drift?
Eliminate all the thugs in the hat.
Hangout?
Where are they?
Where's the thugs?
I have something more important, though.
Where's initiation?
Okay, someone else can handle that.
I'm undercover.
I can't do this job.
I'm undercover right now.
Oh, I don't need to listen to the cop radio.
I gotta listen to my jam.
Okay, how do I...
How do I reverse?
Right here.
And then...
This is...
Okay, there we go.
I forgot how to drift, guys.
Yeah, my cover is too deep for this Whoops Alright, we gotta figure out How to turn here There's a threat that I need to Don't worry I gotta go do my initiation, guys
Yeah, I stole it Guys, I'll just tell them I stole this car They'll think it's so badass Bring a police vehicle to my To my triad Initiation I'll be like, hey guys, yeah, I killed like five cops to get this car and don't think I'm so cool
Yeah, wow, that's hardcore dude bro, that's so fucking hardcore Man, you're in They'll be like, you know what?
You don't even have to do the initiation.
That's already hardcore Yeah, it sends a message you don't fuck with us exactly I'll turn on them.
There we go.
I can't believe all these cars driving on the wrong side of the road.
Don't they know?
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Holy shit, how far is this place?
Are we going to like the middle of nowhere?
Where is... We're going to a hot... Why are we having initiation at the fuck?
Are we gonna kill people hospital patients?
Damn, that's hardcore.
That's...
I like, what are you doing at a hospital?
Oh, it's because the guy, he's...
Oh, I forgot about him.
I forgot he's in the hospital.
A man who would continue...
I thought he got better.
If they were brazen enough to attack a wedding, we have to assume...
18k will be coming after us i know that you are right and i got better my boy uncle you're okay thanks to you sister jang told me about the troubles between you and big smile lee here you must stop this fight at once we must be united against our true enemies yes of course uncle don't worry uncle po as long as i get a promotion He's been a loyal foot soldier to the Sun Han yeah,
very loyal to make him a red pole Very very loyal.
It's like I've been here for like one month He has been selling to school girls and was ordered to stop He switched to the 18k instead make an example of it.
Thank you.
I will if any of your people have not been properly initiated bring them with you Uncle we still need to decide who will lead us Surely initiating someone that's been in the gang for one month is a good idea, right?
Oh, yes, he's a rat.
I can tell.
He's a fucking smell a rat.
Anytime you're like, you've been a loyal person for so long, that's a fucking rat right there.
He's a double agent.
I'm calling it right now.
There's no way.
Why would he say that?
Why?
And keep the...
That's such a huge red flag.
Unlike me, I'm loyal.
I ain't no rat.
Temporary chairman.
Imagine naming your fucking nephew Tuchin.
Like, I'm pretty sure he did not pick that name.
Dragon, thank you for Super Chat.
Thank you.
Has been blessed to watch.
Not only it gave me the chaos expected, but it was also a game I played.
time like but never beat also your inside as a native has been interesting thank you a super child thank you thank you i'm gonna say there's no way he fucking gave himself that name like i don't guys know this but in chinese culture um oh wait there's a there's a strad there give me a sec i gotta give me a sec i gotta go get that strad i need my extra hp but in chinese culture um when you're young you're given a nickname um uh that like all your relatives call you uh like Like,
you don't get to choose your own nickname, by the way.
It does.
One of the nicknames I gave, like, my family gave one of my cousins was literally Nyo-Nyo, which means, like, cow-cow.
Because he, when he was young, he loves to drink milk.
So all my Thai family would call him, like, Nyo-Nyo.
His name's literally, cow-cow.
Yeah.
I think, like, I hated my nickname.
I hated it.
got two nicknames one that my cousins gave me like when i came back um and then the other one my uh my uh relatives would call me i don't wait i don't try to remember what my old one i hated the one that my cousins gave me because they just it was just like my english name butchered into chinese so i hated it i just didn't like the sound of it sounded it sounded like
to say i but i know i'm trying to remember like what my relatives used to say to me like what my my aunts and uncles and grandparents call me it's so long i can't remember it all right call jackie all right father call jackie right now it's way where are you getting a massage man let me tell you He know he's my he's my bro my man But yeah,
I'm what the fuck why there's so many cops?
Oh, because it's a police station.
I was like why there's so many cops at the police station I can't remember I can't remember what my oh shit.
Oh my god.
Oh My mission already started and I might have may or may not have messed up a little just a little bit okay I forgot when the mission starts I can't do anything bad all right hello bus get out where's the massage parlor right here this is a oh he's getting a real massage I was like this doesn't look like my massage parlor what's he doing here Jackie you gonna love this what's going on way well you're about to become a full member of the sun on ye fuck me are you sure 100 yeah baby i fucking did it yeah oh don't worry about it my man it'll be your turn soon jackie they're making me a red pole holy shit way i'm fucking red i'm gonna be a red pole now the dream finally comes true that's crazy this guys been working longer than me and I got the promotion.
It feels like real life.
Just because I knew someone.
Wait, you mean the fucking real massage, real ass massage parlor we're hiding women?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Why did I get a massage from an old man?
It's not fair.
You mean he had women in the back rooms this entire time?
I'm so sad It had women all along
Thank god Well at least now I know I can't believe it There was a fucking actual Women in the backroom And the old man never told me He's like We were in a few legal massage seminars Legal my fucking ass you're right you're right i got the massage from the ceo that's the premium experience you know like when you get a haircut from like the the owner of the hairdresser and you have to pay more you're right i'm so ungrateful guys i got a massage from the ceo instead of the interns how to go man i made her laugh so hard i read that somewhere yeah i think if you're funny she'll fall for you same thing isn't it all right we gotta go here that's the good stuff what the is going on why did it why are people screaming i just parked my car hey where's your wow you think i forgot how to i still remember how to grab that That's right.
Oh, wait, that's not it.
I need you again.
Oh, shit!
It's out.
Hey, looks like...
Oh, shit.
Wait.
Give me a sec.
I was prepping my what?
Hey.
Looks like we gotta turn on the aircon!
Oh, shit.
Give me a sec.
I messed up.
It's been a while.
Looks like we gotta turn on the aircon!
Oh, yeah, that's right.
Oh, you're scared now, aren't ya?
Oh, no, that's a grappler.
That's a grappler.
Oh, my God.
My stomach!
Is there any more?
Oh, there's more.
All right.
You got to turn on the vents.
You don't want some mold growing in.
All right.
Give me a second.
Oh, that's my teammate.
Hey, you want to play Among Us?
Because I think someone's venting.
All right.
Now we just got the wall.
Ain't not as fun.
Not as fun, apparently, though.
Wait, can I do anything with a chair?
No, it's just the wall.
Whoa!
Hey!
No!
Bad!
Get out!
Okay, that's fine.
Don't let me grab you.
Then you get jumped.
Get out of here!
He's holding me back!
Oh, shit.
So you won't get hurt.
that's right he's protecting him he's protecting you from me okay I pressed why oh fuck okay that's fine that's fine I spammed why I don't know why he still grabbed me though oh my god please please stop I'll let it I'll let Jackie handle this I'll just back I'll run I'll bravely run away.
Fight me back.
Don't worry.
You'll be my...
Oh shit!
It's okay.
Things will be fine.
I just gotta regen.
I'm regenning.
Don't worry, I'm just regenning.
No, no, I can regen my HP.
Don't worry.
My heart is beating really fast, but I'm fine.
I might be beating 90 hours per second.
beats per second, but that's okay.
Don't wait, Jack, I got you!
Nice.
We did it.
Guys, I don't think I'm regaining HP, guys.
This does not look like I'm getting my HP back.
This is the star.
Anubis, welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Oh, shit!
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I got it.
That's right.
Get kicked.
Uncle Po sent us.
Who's young?
This guy?
Oh, it's him.
Alright, you got this, Jackie.
Just don't get hit.
Yeah, that's right.
Okay, Jackie, look.
You can literally just jump-crap with him.
Look, he's not paying attention to me.
There we go.
Your turn.
Come on.
You can do it.
Come on, Jack.
Just hit him once.
Look, hit him once.
That's fine.
He's like, he's like, sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, but yet he still hits me.
I'm like, whoa, shit.
He's like, I will do it again.
He says that he keeps kicking me.
I like how he was like apologizing while he was still fighting me.
Oh, I was going to say, like, what?
Jack's like, I'm healthy.
Fuck, he kills, yo.
Let's go, come on.
Let's move.
I can't believe it.
He kills soul for me.
Shit, we have never done that before.
I know.
Oh, he's never killed?
I don't know.
My hands are shaking, man.
Bro, why are you in a game?
I'm sorry, I went on the left side.
I went on the left side.
bro you did drugs but you haven't killed okay I like how the next step is kill us that you've done weed but you haven't shot a guy like what's that's clearly the next step guys after you do drugs and that it's the gateway to murder it's like how video games is a gateway to violence drugs is gateway to murder the drug how do I okay okay it's plastic I was gonna say how do I get across that we sit five stages is it done it's done good good this is what dare worrying us about don't do drugs kids or you'll you'll or you'll shoot someone lives will be forever changed because today you are my brothers yeah we're bound to other by blood sworn to protect each other to the death if necessary with our brotherhood comes duty you will obey our leader in all things and you will show your brothers respect always with our brotherhood comes power the Sun on you does not die the Sun on you does not forget it rewards its son we're gonna be millionaires it protects their businesses and their families it
can for their children.
It protects your businesses and families.
Didn't the uncle almost die?
Enemies with pain, suffering, and death.
And none suffers more than a traitor.
Betray your brother.
You will die a thousand times over.
I will never betray us, brothers.
The sun on me and the gods themselves will burn your soul from your body, crushing ashes without
here.
With them, you become son-on-yee.
Who would do it?
Yes, I am ready, brothers.
You're totally not a cop.
I'll never betray us, guys.
Oh, nice.
That's something for you.
Meet me in an hour.
No better way to show loyalty than by keeping the police jacket on.
Is it a slow day or something?
Pender is very impressed.
I'm not going to lie.
I'm sort of impressed, too.
He wants you to dig around.
See what you can find on Sunny Woe.
Says it's a priority.
I read about it.
I mean, he reps entertainers, dabbles in porn with allegedly some human trafficking mixed in.
Why go after him?
He's not Sun on Yee.
To bring down the Sun on Yee, we have to take down the people who support them, cut off the revenue sources, dismantle the network.
This is how we hit them where it hurts.
Sunny's revenue stream is massive.
Trey, welcome to Tamir Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
I'll see what I can do, Raymond.
By the way, you hear anything about dog eyes?
He seems to have disappeared.
Haven't heard a thing.
Oh, before I forget, Jackie Ma, we're taking him in.
Jackie?
What I read in your reports?
Bro, he's at the bottom tier.
That makes no sense.
Yeah, he's nobody.
He's a criminal way.
You're a cop.
I hate to be a broken record, but it sounds like you're getting attached.
I'm not getting attached.
I'm just...
I'm not a fucking idiot.
Okay, that...
he does nothing to be fair he's the one who vouchs for me and now you're so high up you don't need him he's outlived his usefulness so we're bringing him in i'm taking this up a pendulum this came from taking him in accomplishes nothing and it makes my job harder i'm not doing it you don't have a choice yeah but you're right jack jackie is is a little he has a little bit of a loud mouth directly up he's weak so he'll talk
we want the red place the lieutenants like winston open your I am Winston That's what worries me, Wei You're one of them It's not true Look at me
I haven't killed anybody
Wait, new house?
Oh my Wait, am I living on a boat now?
How do I downgrade?
Why am I living in a boat?
Don't you have to like clean your own like dispose of your own the the sewage yourself if you live on a boat house it's like an rv where you have to like take out your like clean the yes a boat house is a downgrade because there's no sewage pipes there's yeah you have to clean the septic tank yourself there's no fucking pipes to like take the sewage out the sea i don't think i'm legally allowed to just let it all into the ocean i legally i don't think that i can do that time to dump it in the water just do it at night you'll never know true
um yes i am a i am part of the hong kong police force i'm oh wait it's not even a boat house wait is it is this a boat what the fuck is this this is like wait oh my god it's like those little restaurants on a boat i literally converted a restaurant into my own house yeah because like look outside there's like the like the food packaging stuff and oh wait it's a it's literally a fishing boat there's the crab cages why am i living on a boat now yeah
it looks better in the inside than i spent to be fair like who the fuck cares about what's going on the outside it's all about what's the inside do i can i even do i even have air conditioning why do i have like three do i have three tvs where's
the shower how do i shower oh my god i shower where i shit that's uh okay to be fair to be fair that's like literally all bathrooms but like i don't know i like the you know when you're at the curtain next to you even though the toilet's next to the bathtub i do like i do feel more comfortable with a little barrier between between the toilet like oh yeah seriously i yeah the feng shui of this place is pretty We'll admit.
Alright.
Let's go.
Let's go this way.
Yeah.
Zero killer.
Okay, I gotta call Jackie.
We don't need to worry about the zero killer.
That's not as important.
Jackie, how's it going?
Wait, man, good thing you called, man.
I got something, man.
This could be big for us.
Oh?
So I got that plan you were talking about?
Yeah.
You win?
Why is it?
Your car is always in the shop.
Where the fuck is a...
We need a car.
We need to get a car.
Oh, wait.
Oh, my God.
So true.
I hope it's made with real men, too.
Wait, guys, do I have enough to buy?
Wait, I think I...
have enough wait where is the uh where's the okay i think i have enough to buy a swat uniform now all right let's see if i can grab a taxi that's why it makes you a whole man all right where's the taxi there has to be a home taxi where is it also like for any like locals here i i've never understood this but what's the difference between a red And a green taxi I know like I isn't different regions because I always I always get confused between a difference between a red and a green taxi Just a region where the fuck does the green taxi take you like I swear I've never used their green taxi before is oh oh the rich areas never
Red ones go fast That's it.
Oh, it's the new territory.
All right.
All right, because I never, I've never actually been on a green taxi.
I even, there's a blue taxi?
When, when did we get a blue taxi?
Wait, come on.
Guys, hello, I want to take a taxi.
Oh my God, is it because it's not green?
It's...
It doesn't...
It's because it's not green.
I'm in the new territories right now.
I can't...
I can't take these cabs because it's not green.
And like...
Speaking of green taxis, they don't want to take me anywhere.
Alright, I guess I have to drive.
Can't believe it.
If I can't take a cab, I steal your cab.
Yeah, get out, police.
legally you have to let me steal your car see oh my god look oh my god look they they actually are fine with it all right here you
what the fuck was this guy listening to oh my god how am I on a mission I haven't taken any oh Jackie I forgot about the Jackie mission okay I think I have enough wasn't it 300k guys for the um for the legendary outfit i hope it is
no i don't want to listen that what was the what was the squad unit because i have 350k right now
does anyone remember how much it actually costs i'm on the highway to it
this music makes me want to go fast
.
all right nice all right smooth all right oh my gosh please tell me i'm able to afford it that is like my goal
oh is it because i would oh it's because i'm in i'm i'm in a mission so i can can't fast travel.
Alright.
This is the uniform I've been wanting to get since I... Yes!
We can afford it!
Yes!
You now take... Alright, nice.
Not something I don't usually sell the triads, but okay.
This was it, right?
Yeah, this was the uniform I really wanted to Now they'll never know.
Wait, what gun do I have?
I have grenade mode?
Okay.
I'm on a...
God, fuck, I'm on a mission.
I can't use it.
I just get a gun.
How do I get out of here?
Oh, that's it.
Nice.
It comes with a gun.
I think this was supposed to cost like This was supposed to cost like 10,000 But the gun was like 200 and the gun was like $340,000 sorry $340,000 Hello Get out You have to legally leave now That's right leave Oh hey, I used to where would you like to go So Where was he actually taking you sir?
You want me to drop you off somewhere or you're just all right.
He's just with me now I got a little I got a little buddy or a buddy system
I'm okay throughout this entire time.
I've been trying to remember my Chinese nickname.
I actually don't remember that's how much It's crazy.
I remember the one that I hated I remember I remember the nickname that I fucking hated that was given to me by my cousins but I don't even remember the nickname that my grandparents and my relatives, my aunts and uncles gave me it was so irrelevant to me
I'm like, was it that one?
I'm like, no, that has to be someone else's nickname, right?
It was like I think it was like, it was...
Oh!
No, I had several.
It's because, like, okay, I remember now.
It's because, um, um, my relatives gave me, like, two different nicknames, so I could never remember it.
That's why I don't know.
I just, I always made fun of my cousin's nickname, though.
The one that's called Cow Cow, Nyo-Nyo.
Just because I thought it was so...
I just thought it was funny.
That's what I'm saying.
Sometimes, like, there's no way these people gave themselves that nickname.
It's always by a relative.
Just because he just loved milk.
He just really loved drinking milk.
Okay, make your way.
Hey, we have, you have three passengers now?
Wait, where's Jackie?
Wait, I thought I was picking up Jackie.
Like, wait, where is he?
there's just two of us where's jackie all right wait here wait here wait hey hey i said wait in that sir let's head to kennedy town oh hey there's jackie oh jackie came back he was just waiting for the other guy to leave down to the shipyard 18k are bringing in a big shipment of jewelry goods from a big heist they pulled in stay nice i'm gonna tell you how to help where did he go
wanted in the front seat.
He was like, I called shotgun.
You should take a few days off.
It don't look so good.
I haven't been sleeping too well.
It's because he shot again?
Every time I close my eyes, I see that guy.
First time?
I guess it's just...
Man, I don't know.
Sometimes I wake up and I have this bad feeling.
I've never had that before.
Well, you join a game.
Low key.
Good payday.
This job is not low-key.
She's good.
I haven't talked to her.
Come on, Jackie.
She was your dream girl.
Yeah, I know.
But maybe when we're done this job, I'll give her one of the pieces.
That's great, Jack.
You know, she'll love it.
It's so low-key, you know, shooting a guy.
The low is so low.
Carrying firearms in public?
Damn.
That's low-key.
bro oh wait there's a shrine all right we gotta grab that too i feel like i grabbed so many shrines but i have like zero upgrades yeah
he's talking to a man who breaks yeah exactly i'm like i mean jackie you've seen me shot so many people like at one point when i shot the 50th guy i think you're coping when you say that um they're all okay i follow jackie I think at that point, you might be repressing something.
Not all of them head to the hospital at that point.
You always have options, yeah.
You think so?
I don't know, way.
I don't know if that's true.
You're like, Joki, I don't think that 50th person went to the hospital.
No problem.
There are heavy duty tools in this shed just over there.
You get the tools.
I'll scout the containers.
Meet me there when you have someone to cut the lock.
Yeah, I need to grab some pliers.
yeah sunglasses at night oh my gosh I dropped my cough drop where did it go oh no tried fast-talking away past anyway okay I dropped my cough I don't want my dog I don't want that to like randomly joint this cough drop I don't know how that will affect dogs and I don't really want to find out okay fast-talk who Oh,
yeah?
Hey, guys.
It's not suspicious at all, right?
What the fuck?
Why can't I?
Excuse me.
I'm trying to...
Okay, there we go.
Apparently, I can't do that.
Hello.
Yeah, it was just a short...
I'm practicing...
I'm filming for my parkour YouTube video.
Okay.
It's called Garbage Man Doing Parkour.
Try to get thousand subscribers right now.
Parkour!
Oh,
blow up, trust guys.
Parkour!
Oh, what the fuck?
Wait.
That's the garbage.
How can I be a garbage man if I can't parkour garbage cans?
Hello.
Hey, who are you?
Hey, keep your voice down.
I'm sneaking into that warehouse up there and you're making way too much money.
Shut the hell up.
I could just be like, I'm the new guy.
But it's like, all right.
Shut the fuck up or I'm gonna beat your ass.
Okay.
Speech 100 right there.
All right, nice.
Hey, it worked.
You're right.
It did.
Take the cutting tool.
Wait, but what about my hand grenade?
Wait, where's my hand grenade?
I could just blew it up.
This way.
Yeah, I rode a natural 20.
I like with the cops.
I'm like, yeah, I'm just a new garbage man.
And the other guy, I'm like, I'm going to beat your ass if you don't fucking shut up.
If you don't shut your mouth.
All right.
And I had to jack you.
Pacor!
Wait, how do I get there?
Oh.
I thought it was a gate that was, like, fully closed.
By the way, Doki, if they want to participate in a cockfight, go to the location in Canningtown.
You can bet...
Oh, my God!
Wait, eight.
Oh, what are you?
Can I cut this?
Can I cut the thugs?
Oh, my God.
It's the cockfight for...
the rich we're moving up in the world guys i just need 100k can i have a loan can i cut people with this wait guys give me a sec i'm trying to figure out oh i can't wait this is better chop chop chop chop stabby stabby oh it's fine chop chop chop
That's right.
What are you gonna do against the bus song?
I played silk song Ocean man
This is welcome to welcome to future london Works right Chop chop That's right Why use... Why use my fist?
Chop chop!
You know, all I'm saying is that this is definitely more convenient.
Oh shit, sorry.
Sorry to Jackie.
Wait, can I accidentally kill Jackie?
Oh, I can't.
It won't let me.
Alright, nice.
This is London in the future.
it i
wish they at the amazon warehouse great work man we got him man what the what you can just do that wait where's my where's my cutter this was like the best weapon i've ever got
okay we gotta catch up to the truck to be fair there's no way that like a truck is faster than the motorcycle there's no way like what kind of engine would that truck have i don't know what yeah that's what i'm saying why is it still following traffic laws too like i'm already up against it how do i i don't remember guys does anyone remember how to do that thing where we're at the jump on top of the Okay,
never mind.
It's not following traffic.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, was it A?
It was hold A.
Okay.
Hold A.
I actually don't remember how it is.
No, no, not that one.
The one in front of you.
There we go.
I was gonna say, did I miss?
Yeah.
All right.
I got this.
I'm almost there.
Yay!
It's our truck now.
All right, where do we go?
Oh, yeah, I need to help Jackie in the back.
Holy fuck, Jackie.
What happened to the trauma?
Cock-sucker.
Let's go fence this stuff.
It's the usual place.
Oh.
Let's go.
fire before but okay hey hey we got bar your car yeah here i wouldn't leave you jackie no just damn way i wouldn't leave you jackie yeah i always like can i just drive there without him i wonder i'll always appreciate it i should be doing a better job getting you back she's not your fault way i'm you know i'm thinking about a lot of things but Jackie you're almost there not our friendship you're almost there Jackie you got this come on I'm training him he's in the red poles now friends yeah we're good friends this is what bros do I'm training him for the next boxing match make him run the hole he's got this he's got a marathon next week guys It's this Rocky montage.
I wonder if he could die, but another car accident runs him over.
Wait, where did he go?
There he is.
You got this, Jackie.
We're almost there.
You're gonna make it.
I believe.
You're gonna beat.
You're gonna beat what's his name?
The guy with a face tattoo.
Let's do it.
Follow me.
it Jackie yeah
he's gonna beat up Mike Tyson guys I believe in him how did he know we were there I need to talk to you meet me at the K bar in Soho what's this is Chinese medicine oh yeah I need some herbal tea I got my best friend arrested after I make him run ten miles am I an asshole nah yeah a real cool cold card that can make DMV pulses ram cars and have catlings is there anything you know super chat they can thank you wait where's the okay I could in intensive care okay i could wait what the fuck what's this hide piper redux oh it's just like a special mission okay um i want to dude where's kennedy guys where's the cockfight and where is kennedy by the way is it here Is this a rich people cockfight?
Yeah, right here.
But I go here.
Don't worry, Jackie.
I'll free you soon.
Alright.
Do they take me to there?
No, they don't.
God damn it.
I got...
Alright, I gotta borrow your car.
That's your own fault for not offering the surface.
Wait, do I have 100k first?
How much money do I have?
Wait, how much money do I have?
I don't think I have 100k.
Okay.
I you know what fuck it maybe they'll take less than 100k bets Oh I have it's okay I think they'll take 2k Don't not too poor right
I can slowly get there
All right don't worry I believe
this way all right we gotta go this way we got to go to the rich people cockfighting these roosters were our purebred roosters they've been they're so purebred that
they might have one or two more they might have too many chromosomes that's how purebred they are Oh Oh All right, I may or may not be too poor.
It's okay.
I can watch on the I can watch through the gates guys They might have the idea they're so pure bread that they might they might they have like yeah more chromosomes or more power Yeah, they have four they have like six toes that means more scratch scratchy scratchy All right,
we'll watch through the gates because I have to pee real quick.
I'll be back
They checked my credit They checked my This this cockfight is so It's so expensive That you have to send in your credit score To bet on the roosters
Back Rice, Nexi, Johnny, Bears Thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you Alright, let's I'm not under tax bracket apparently They checked my credit score I'm I may or may not be welcome there.
Oh my god, this is where all the film, I like how, I like how it's p- Wait, are these just p-and-g?
2D pictures?
Wait, let's see.
It's just, it's just a p-and-g of some fucking chickens.
What the fuck?
You have some rubber chicken and they're just p-and-g.
This is a remastered.
Before in Sleeping Dogs, in the non-remaster, it was actually just like MS Paint drawing of a stick figure of a chicken.
In the remaster, they got actual photos.
Okay, let's steal this van.
Stop, police!
Let's steal this SUV.
Alright, nice.
uh intensive care we gotta go there
they'll never know how would a tri-end member honestly that's actually so smart if you own an suv as a tri-end member they'll never know like why the would a child tri-end member drive an suv holy is so slow guys i don't think i'm strong enough i'm gonna take this car i'm definitely not strong enough This SUV is so slow.
Give me your car.
These are true purebreds.
Yeah, I'm leaving the super chat.
Thank you.
No, as long as the vans, not white.
They'll never know.
Ooh, da bino?
Ooh.
I want to have...
Oh, my God.
I crave hot pot right now.
Wait, what the fuck?
Why does it keep changing?
Wait, can I just shortcut this?
Oh, I can just shortcut this.
I was gonna sit.
Alright, there you go.
You know what, it's right?
I want... Oh my gosh.
I crave, like, hot pot.
And, um...
I know there's places where you can have your own little hot pot.
Like, your own little mini pot.
Um, but, like...
I hate it when if you wanted to have like Korean barbecue or whatever or Yaki Miku You have to eat with somebody because like the portions are just way too much
That grinds my gears Because it's like you gotta have someone to eat this with or like it's just too much Same with like hot pot too
Because I remember when I went to like I told you guys the story i went to korean barbecue i was like do you guys have any combos for like one person and they're like no you got it it's we only have like two or more and i'm like okay i guess i'll guess i'll just order a two-person combo for myself not that's it's not that sad right
it's it's not that sad
Deeper too, I guess
It's like It's like trying to go to Haidilau by yourself We also don't know Haidilau Haidilau is like one of the best hot pop Like franchise hot pop Places in the world And it's so It's like what it's also very expensive It's very expensive but it's actually Like what the best hot pop place you can to because they treat you like they treat you so well i love hidey loud
it's so good but like it's so sad if you go there by yourself that's the it's just it's so you have to find people to go hidey loud with it's so sad
yeah it would be really sad but it's so good I'm serious.
Wait,
get down here.
Jesus, Ricky, what's happening?
It's the 18K.
They're all over the damn place.
Wait, what?
Shit.
How did they know?
Wait, what's over there?
Oh, there's a camera.
Okay, give me a sec, uncle.
I gotta hack this.
How do I hack?
Oh, it's over here.
I know this is important, but I have to hack this.
Okay, one, two, three.
Oh, I have four attempts?
Okay, invalid placement.
Okay, five, six, seven, eight.
Okay.
Four and eight are invalid.
Okay, four, eight, nine.
Zero.
All right, there you go.
Nice.
I'm so smart.
wait defeat the nearby thugs oh shit wait time remaining oh fuck oh my god i'm sorry wait get out get out for god but i didn't realize it's time i'm sorry it's okay i can make it in five seconds wait how far oh my god no he's dead he's dead he's he's dead i don't think i can i thought i thought that was for hacking i thought that i thought that was like how much it the time for hacking the the camera i was like damn whoa i'm time for hacking this jesus christ where to drive buddy i'm so smart guys i think you might be dead watch out there's a timer solid thank you for the super chat thank you thank you I'm like,
don't worry Uncle Poe.
I'm coming over to help you.
But first, let me hack the surveillance camera real quick.
But yeah, if you guys ever want suggestions for like, if you guys ever want to do hot pot and you want like the best experience, go to Heidi Lau.
It's like a big franchise, but like, um, um, it has like all the best, like, like you can.
There's like all the best soups and stuff too
With who The only downside is don't I would suggest maybe don't go buy our stuff because it's it's It's not idea That's right.
Oh shit Boom Some reason I just don't see that happening That's five.
See?
I got this.
Oh, shit.
There's a statue over there.
Give me a sec.
Wait, why does the hostile?
Why did the hostile stole a fucking Kung Fu statue?
Nice.
That's it.
Get out of here.
Now get up or I'll shoot you in the balls.
Too late.
You didn't get up fast enough.
Wait, how do I get to this?
elevator see there's no timer now oh i have to go through there we go i don't need to to be slowed down wait my gun is so good come on poke your head out god it's so tempted i don't know those people are like i don't want to do the evil route i feel so bad i'm like i'm so sad i just oh my god she's just standing there like she's she has no survivability instincts just like me like what are you doing why are you just oh my god i need to shoot i want to shoot you to teach you a lesson i do not shoot the nurses it's just she's just right there wait what like i just want to teach her about being safe like that's on her like why is she just standing there.
Okay, I know there's someone behind me.
Also, these glasses should be bulletproof.
Okay, where's the other guy?
There we go.
Wait, is he alive?
No, he's not.
Oh, wait.
Someone needs help.
Who needs help?
Don't worry, ma'am.
She's like Don't hit me, I'll give you all Really?
Give me your money right now What if I?
She's like, don't kill me, I beg of you Don't worry, ma'am I'm just gonna teach you a lesson Oh, wait, what?
What the fuck?
Oh my god Are you like, immortal?
But you might be a fucking god or some shit Stop.
Please, Toki.
She's already 12 hours into a ship.
We have a nurse shortest ever since COVID, Toki.
Don't do this.
She has actual toes of steel.
Yeah, she has plot armor.
Sprinklers.
Get out of here.
How?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
What am I built like?
Okay Where are the cops?
I would you would assume like like 12 cars would be here right now We're like next to the police station, too Guys, we're next to the police station.
I don't understand They should be here right now You are I'm undercover What?
There's one more guy that's still alive.
There he is.
Our uncle Poe's room.
Surely he's still alive, right?
I'm the only...
Apparently, I'm the only active cop in this entire city.
18K shut off the power.
Uncle Poe is on life support.
Oh.
We don't get backup power running right away.
He won't make it.
Okay, look.
Yeah, that's not good.
I'm on it.
These guys are beginning to annoy me.
is spent on me and me only oh fuck I could take a couple of shots oh yeah I am literally bulletproof I have a I actually have plot armor all right oh there's backup power here nice let me hack this real quick in my HKPD app as long as he doesn't look as long as he doesn't look on my screen we're fine okay one is I'll put that here three oh wait four five six okay five seven eight nine okay nine eight there you go easy pack the planet okay I'll get back to Ricky all right where is he thank God they have flashlights for easier for easier aim there we go where oh there I was like where are they how do you know oh my god six light who bad you died for it he's like those never this is it this is my time to shine all right I'm waiting I mean at least he died looking sick as fuck but do I have no more oh my god where's my gun wait where is my gun this sucks this is worse than the it's worse than the pistol the pistol was so good yeah I know you're here there you let's grab the shotgun
actually shotgun might be better oh my god that's a lot of people okay it might not be better they'll look cool as hell boom oh yeah never mind I was right I was fucking right okay there's no way you take like five shots in a row nice double kill there's no way you take five gun like five pellets in a row that was close nice work no man that was awesome who's our backup who's looking out for us fuck no one ever looks out for you in this town I don't know man feels like the game has changed this fat was the was the bulletproof fest even amongst rival triads now we're killing each other at weddings even in the fucking hospital.
And for what?
Let's get out of here.
Wait, are we not going to check on that Koppol?
More cops.
Oh, now they're here.
Now they're here.
I was going to say, how the fuck?
Now they're here after I killed everybody?
Man.
I feel like we had budget cuts or some shit At least it's like a straight road.
It should be fine.
We're so fast
Did he shot my tire?
How did I die?
How the fuck did I die?
Oh wait, I have an idea
oh oh it's okay it's okay i did it okay that wasn't as smooth oh my god okay that was not oh my god they popped they already popped the tires okay never mind i might have fucked up they oh wait money give me a sec i might get arrested but at least i got some money oh i can't open it oh we're on an active crime scene oh wait i can't I can't even get back in the sky.
Oh, I can.
Wait, what if I leave him?
Get in the car.
Oh, my God, my fucking tires.
Okay, I'm leaving him.
Wait, what if I just...
Wait, I got a plan.
There we go.
Come on, get in the car.
Get in the car.
Get in the... Get in the fucking...
Okay, we're leaving him.
It should be fine.
Wait, I got it!
No!
Wait, I have an idea.
Okay, this is a brilliant plan.
Watch this.
This plan is brilliant.
Guys, I have a plan.
Okay, wait.
I got an idea.
If I make them all...
Alright, here.
Watch this.
And then he just needs to get in the car.
He just needs, okay, we're leaving him.
So now that they're all out of the car, I can just, oh my God, don't leave Ricky.
Please, Ricky, get in here.
Get in here before.
Ricky, please, Ricky.
Where's Ricky?
Where is Ricky?
Get in the car.
Ricky, please get in the car.
Now that they're all out of the car, now that they're all out of the car, we did it.
It's just...
Okay, I got it.
Okay, we gotta make them stop in the car.
Make them get out of the car and we leave.
This plan.
It's brilliant.
Okay, I need them to get out of the car, though.
Come on, get out of the car.
Get out of the car and fight me.
I just need you to get out of the car.
Okay, that's fine.
We'll do a little ring around the rosy.
Both...
there we go there we go we're fine I just want if they all get out of the car
oh no we got we might have to swap cars it's just that easy oh my god how did they pop a tire no it's fine I can still run this.
There's no way they can do this turn.
This sick-ass turn.
Okay, maybe there is that way.
And then I'll do another turn.
They'll never expect it.
And then I'll turn like this.
Oh my god.
Okay, this is a little awkward.
Maybe he'll get out of the car.
Maybe they'll all get out of the car.
I don't know.
Okay.
there we go it's just that easy look now we just have two cars okay now we have three cars but all I do I do a U-turn oh fuck okay I didn't expect a third car okay all I do is I do another U-turn and and then I do this they'll never expect it they'll never expect it and then after I U-turn here oh my god it's fine they're just helping me U-turn better after oh my god and then after that I U-turn here how is my car alive and then I U-turn here and they'll never expect it I think I might need a new car it's Okay,
and then after that, after that, I grab a new car right here.
And then, Ricky please get in here, Ricky please.
And then after that, because he got out of the car, I go this way.
Look, this is a 20 step plan.
we're only at step two and now now that they're all out of the car because I got out of my car we should be safe what how did I die I don't understand we're still on step five I What happened to my 10-step program?
Part A!
That's fine.
I think I know what to do.
Part B, flat.
We gotta go to flat D, tilt E.
It's fine.
I just gotta drive somewhere.
I just got it.
Oh my god.
Now there's like 20 cops.
Where were they when we were in the hospital?
I have an idea.
I just keep driving.
Why didn't I think of this before?
I'm glad you showed up, right?
Why did I think of this before?
I just keep driving.
Cops might be watching the place.
Hey, Ricky.
Keep it tight.
They just got a new budget plan.
All right.
See you.
Bye.
the super chat thank you thank you best car chase ever see you just gotta trust the plan
all right what's my other go to bed oh i gotta return you know i'll return the jade statue i might as well actually now i'll put that in my house wheels of fury go to bed it's ep time wait is that money oh it's a security i don't care enough about that.
There's no risk involved.
I was okay with doing a security camera when the hospital's getting invaded just because of the thrill of the risk, you know?
The high pressure situation that I was in.
We made it more exciting.
Yeah, when I composed life was on the line, I felt that adrenaline rush.
Oh, there it is!
See, there's the yellow cataxe!
I told you guys, look.
There it is.
There's the yellow taxis.
I didn't even realize we had blue taxis.
See, I wasn't making things up.
Alright, we gotta go home now.
Where's one?
Not home.
Oh, here.
Alright, we gotta go eating time.
We had a very long day.
What if it happened to my gun?
Can I get my gun back if I...
Do I get it back?
I just lose it forever?
What's the point?
Oh, wait, that's my bathroom.
Where's my bed?
Oh, there it is.
Keeping time.
A long day.
This is not my bedroom.
It's at school to bed.
Okay.
Oh, do I have to change?
Or do I have to change into my fucking sleepwear?
This is what...
This is the sleepwear.
This is my sleeping clothes.
Very comfy.
I thought I had to go to bed.
Yeah, see, I said go to bed.
I'm literally next to my bed.
Oh, there it is.
Yeah.
I had... This is my bed wear.
It makes me feel extra safe.
There we go.
Psycho through.
Wait, you ready to step up to the big time?
Got a celebrity geek for you.
Meet me at Sunny Woes.
Okay, but first up, I got a date.
What?
Wait, where's my date?
so many wait i just saw something from not ping where was that from you saw that right it said not ping
important visitor wheels the fruit wait i want to hang out with my with my lady girl
i can't even call him what the is rolling why are you in my contacts list roland got any work for me yeah sure samson your typical deadbeat moron is hiding out on an overpass in north point well my ladies i've been on a date in a while i gotta i've been using a massage parlor a bit too much
that's silly me there's no such thing as too much massages what's up tram you looking for anything in particular i need a coop stand by for details i need a coop all right I guess we do...
Wait, not this.
Important visitor?
I'm a boy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Just in case you missed my earlier super chat, you can participate in the Aberdeen Martial Art Club.
It pays 150K on First Side Club.
Jesus.
That's a lot.
Where the fuck are they getting all that money?
Can't believe it.
They were like, talk to not paying.
And I was like, ooh, daytime.
And then she, like, ghosted me.
Yeah, there's no such thing as too much massage, guys.
Oh, crap.
Where's the parking?
Where's my car?
Oh, there it is.
Wait, can I just fast travel?
Where is this?
How far?
Uh, I'm gonna go to the clothing shop and then...
Yeah.
Uh...
Nah, I can drive there.
It's alright.
JK.
JK, there's no closer location.
Uh, yeah, my car.
Alright.
I feel like that guy lives my life for like even 10 minutes, he'll cry.
He ain't built like me.
Or maybe just like 30 seconds.
all right well go meet the new visitor like they're still like there's a zero killer lead when are you ready and then i just it's just gonna be like a case unsolved case right there i guess we'll never find it's because the zero killer is actually ocean man that's why ocean man was never caught because i never took the case to solve it well well well look who decided to join us it's good to see you come on in you sure you don't want to fuck her a little before you start there's no problem at all what just have a swing by your hotel on the way to come back man i'm good but we could do a photo shoot or whatever and look i'm sure it'd be fun and all but that's not why i'm here dude ah you don't know what you're missing this baby will fuck you in the way your wife never could the infamous sunny whoa that's me infamous and notorious glad you could come by ricky's told me all about you this is king was good he's producing vivian lu's next big hit way here's the real deal hi hi try yeah
cleaver's guns castrations whatever you want way why don't you take king out on the town and show him around i'm gonna show you hong kong king Nothing's off limits.
Okay, maybe not.
Oh.
Get nasty.
Whoa.
It's not the Hong Kong I remember.
Yeah, I mean, actually, that sounds all right.
If you don't mind showing me around.
Yeah, sure.
I wish I could go with you, players.
Don't worry, kid.
I know the best massage part is.
Yo, it was real nice to meet you, Sonny.
Let's do it.
Yeah, let's go do the legal stuff.
I've been thinking.
We need to get her a movie roll of some sort.
Hey, I think we'll start at the K bar.
The VIP room should give us what we need.
Hey, it's your town, man.
Don't worry, King.
Whoops.
Don't worry.
I'll show you the real Hong Kong.
Just this one time.
Man, that guy's a piece of work.
Man, he's a fucking clown.
You asked me.
But he literally was like, don't worry.
Don't worry.
I'll...
I'll help you cheat on your wife.
And he's like, what?
She's right here.
I got some other business to discover.
Huh?
But I don't think my partner's back in the stay through want to be in bed with that guy.
What kind of business?
I got friends.
The guys I grew up with.
They got a real good import and retail thing going.
But they could use a good Hong Kong.
Access to that good Asian product.
Wait, drugs?
Well then, I guess this is going to be like one of them old school businessmen.
me around town and try to figure out where we're a good fit where is my uber going like what like what are we what are we trying to do here king i thought we're i thought you just wanted to i just wanted to get a karaoke i just wanted oh my god is that is that a cyber truck right in front me is don't worry care i'm gonna get you the good shit
damn this this korean this ktv is crazy it has its own valet yay ktv
let me find us the right kind of audience What?
Oh, I thought I said fight girls.
Okay, fine, girls.
Oh, wait, let me, give me a sec.
I need to grab that statue.
Uh, hello.
Any girls wanna party with me and King?
Wait, is that her?
Is that a bitch that...
Oh, wait, no, that's someone else.
Sorry, she was blonde.
I confused her because she was blonde.
But listen, I saw you looking at my friend and I figured you realized he's a famous American celebrity.
And I just wanted to ask if you mind keeping it a secret.
I thought it was Emma.
How can I say no?
If you're not doing anything, maybe I can buy you silence with a drink.
Wanna join us?
That's very nice.
I thought it was Emma Stone.
So you're from Russia?
Yes.
How'd you guess?
I'll call it a hunch.
Oh, you.
Oh.
Wait, is that massage parlor over there?
I mean, it's okay.
I'll be right back.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha.
Ha.
All right, King.
Have fun.
I'll be right back.
I got something important.
I got something important to do.
Don't worry, King.
I'll be right back.
I'm so stressed out.
I'm so stressed.
Wait, where is she?
Wait, where is this?
Is it here?
Wait, how do I access it?
The chat just gave me hands.
And like, they can't bait me like this.
I have a problem and I need an answer to it right now No, they can't Wait, is it upstairs?
Oh, it might be upstairs, you're right I can't get a massage on a mission That's when I'm most stressed out Oh my god, you're right Oh my god, it was It's because I have a It's because I'm on a mission Where am I supposed to have A good time.
I don't have a problem.
I swear.
Want to buy us girls a drink?
I don't know.
My friend and I are going to enjoy your company.
Try us on and see what you get.
Whoa.
How did you join my friend in there?
I'll be in in a second.
Turn more women.
Oh my god.
How many women does he...
Do we need?
Oh damn.
You okay, miss?
Wait, poor guy, that my girl, so why did you fuck off?
I'm son on ye, motherfucker.
Now get out of here before I'm here.
Oh, man, no, sorry.
I didn't know who you were.
That's my girl now.
You guys seem like you's getting a little push.
Liliana.
You work here?
Yes.
So, are you allowed to join the customers for a drink?
Oh, that sounds nice.
By the way, I'm Wei.
I don't think I've seen you here before.
I'm Liliana.
Yeah, yeah.
I usually don't come to places like this.
I'm here for my friend.
Well, if you ever want to hang out, the place is not like this.
I'm Mr. Solio, girl.
I'd like that.
Can I call you?
Sounds good.
Thanks.
Give me a call sometime.
Guys, is that my fifth girlfriend?
Oh, my God.
Guys, I'm in.
I got my fifth girlfriend.
Oh, I think he has a type.
I feel bad for these two.
They're like, oh, they're on their phones now.
know king's type guys i wait is this the snow bunny mind control is
who knew hong kong was full of such beautiful women friendly too how do you not know hong kong have beautiful girls you just had to come oh she's not even from hong kong makes your king never makes that mistake again you can count on us baby we love american men don't we tina all right way why don't you show us what you got i was gonna say they're not even locals these girls are from russia what do you mean
i'll show you mine if you show me yours same character yokia with king and the girls That is.
We have a real...
What are they talking about?
Why are they gossiping?
He's like, if I have a boyfriend, I would love to move out.
Why are you girls gossiping about?
Oh,
they're talking about movies.
They're like, it's been so long since I went to a movie.
all right why are we not saying yet oh hit me with your best shot but oh wait let's do rob robert palmer i haven't done karaoke in a while
i know this song i thought king was supposed to sing with me what is he doing i don't know this song Holy shit I have some pipes
I need you Wait Where did she come from?
Give me the news Hot piece of loving you She just showed up
She just randomly showed up to dance at my party.
I think I'm the only one that's having me and that other girl.
are having a good time.
We're the only ones that are actually doing a karaoke part.
Yeah.
So, doctor, give me the news.
Got a hot case of loving you.
No pills gonna cure my ill.
I got a hot case of loving you.
Meow.
I did so good!
I don't even think they were paying attention.
Oh!
Wait, where did my dancer go?
My backup dancer?
Don't worry, I got you.
You know in the States, I'd have to take you to a little room in the back.
Let me show you how we do it here, baby.
Okay, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait, can I though?
Is that actually...
Can I actually just...
Oh no, I can't.
Where's my town?
Least I can do.
As I did...
I was just curious, guys, guys.
I just wanted to see... I was just testing...
I was just limit testing the game.
child's just limited testing I was trying to test the limits of the game guys nothing else why can't I get a massage do I am I still on this mission yeah we're stress testing oh wait he left what I was following him oh my god sorry I was trying I was too busy with something else my town least I could do it's
okay to I'll just lie and say you're not a freak.
LNQ is a super chat thing.
I don't have a problem.
I don't need an intervention.
If you ever want to change a scene, I'll keep that in mind.
Where am I supposed to?
Oh, is that his car?
Did he, like, drove away without me?
Oh, he got beat up by the thugs because too busy.
Whoa!
What's this?
We got...
Oh, fuck.
I'm sorry to tell you, we have a scheduled power outage today!
Okay.
Holy shit.
He's going at it.
Wait, I heard that...
I heard there's a special one with the car.
Oh, no.
Never mind.
Wait, do I have to, like...
Maybe I have to put it at the seat.
Okay, I want to try the special animation.
No!
How dare you?
How dare you interrupt this?
This is important.
Oh, shit.
Your Uber's here.
Alright, there's one more.
I think you might be sus.
Because I... Wait, oh, he's dead.
Never mind.
We'll do it for this guy.
Wait, where did he get a knife?
I gotta watch this.
Where did King grab?
Oh, my God, King.
This is nasty-ass shit you got going on.
Remind me not to fuck with you.
Oh my.
Okay.
I don't know how I don't know where he got that knife
Well, then King got moves I'm going back in a week or so.
All right.
I'll tell my boys I've got the man for all right.
Don't want to start slow, but I'm guessing they can move as much product as you can ship Oh, this could be huge man.
These boys got some big ideas, too.
I'm talking all the legit shit the rush move rush hour looks a little different
like how we had that the police station is right next to a ktv a very legal ktv i can swing that for you i still got contact stateside who could set up the other side of things
or like nobody called a report on a bunch of people getting changed a sunny walk now man come on that's what's good about it everybody's a fucking moron you come in with muscle and money and you too can call the shots you got a point
queen all right we're here i like how you sort of see him still holding the knife in the car it's real cool to meet you we see you around yeah for sure hopefully first night of many well then looks like this is the beginning of a friendship all right man take care see ya bro yeah it's so legal it's next to a police station they'll never expect it wait does that mean okay I got Ileana's phone I have Ileana's phone number oh my god I also got like oh I have triad connections in the music industry now that's right I control Taylor Swift now this Eliana!
Eliana?
Yes, who is this?
It's me.
It's Way.
I didn't expect you to actually call.
Really?
I'd like to hang out.
You free?
Yeah, I'm off work in a little while.
Can you meet me at paper?
Oh my god, it's my first day!
Oh my god, it's my second day!
Oh my god, it's pink!
Wait.
Wall Street.
Okay, make...
Make Eliana sweat?
Hello?
Oh!
it's like because it's so hot outside right right what what what does that mean what does that mean oh because my hands are so sweaty right palm sweaty mom spaghetti what the fuck out of music am i listening to
all right but her song can't listen to Let's go to real FM radio.
That's how real it is.
All right.
Eliana, I'm here, girl.
Oh my gosh, she lives next to the massage parlor.
Oh my gosh, she's perfect.
Wait, where is it?
Is it?
Oh, it's here.
Oh, it's because she lives.
Oh, it's because it's off work hours.
all right give me a sec oh it's because she's at there okay i'll be right back she's perfect she she works next to the massage bar there i got sexy want to party all right i gotta get my body ready we gotta warm up we gotta warm up before we do the real deal you know the real massage she might just she might be the one of many Stress you come right back Guys,
I'm almost there.
I just need one more stamp and I get it one free massage On my loyalty card on my voucher card.
Hello, Yana.
I'm here.
Oh, a play.
Yes, it's nice to have a break.
Let's go back Hey there.
Hey, yeah, I'm going for a run.
I like to work up a good sweat now and then you you could talk me into it Follow me.
Let's see if you can keep up.
Oh shit.
Oh Oh my okay when I when she said a run I thought we're gonna go jogging on a park Oh my god.
She's a Russian parkour But I wonder if I can just
She grab a little NPC can I make him stop?
Oh, she's not I imagine how beautiful like we're done now iliana we're done
come on way this is parkour for children this is nothing for you you lived in the states
all right i'm ahead that's right i win
wow you can really run have to keep in shape Yeah, me too.
Wait, you do this for fun.
Yes.
Damn.
What else do you do for fun?
Oh, you really want to?
Oh, is that okay?
Yes, it's fine.
I like it.
Oh!
Really?
I've been thinking about this for a while.
Oh, let's do it.
Oh.
What happened?
I'm back outside.
What were we doing?
Out here?
Guys, we held hands outside.
That's what she meant, right?
Like, holding hands outside?
That's what she meant when she's like, I haven't done this in a while.
Guys, I knew that warm-up was...
good for something.
Alright, I'll take my mini car.
Yeah, my sweaty handle.
Real men don't karaoke.
Holy shit, this is a fast-ass mini fetal car.
Wait, what?
Where were the cops?
Oh my god, oh my god, there were so many cops.
Oh my, I did not realize I was next to police station yeah guys i took off my gloves for that too yeah we held hands without protection okay but they won't expect a double u-turn oh my god they don't expect a triple u-turn the uno reversal and then the the u-turn of the u-turn i made a circle And now I'm gonna go here.
And now I'm gonna go here.
And then it's Ring Around the Rosie.
And I'm gonna go here again.
And they'll never expect it.
Look, they're stuck.
They're stuck in the Ring Around the Rosie.
They don't know.
Okay, they might know.
Oh shit, they still don't know.
The zero turn, exactly.
Okay, where is the...
Where the fuck is the other mission?
Oh wait, there you go.
Fast girls.
See?
Oh my god, where was the cops there?
Oh!
I keep forgetting there's a police station next to me.
I just bumped into him.
It's not like he's dead or...
Okay, wait, I got an idea.
Watch this.
And
then...
It just works.
It just...
Just get out of the car.
And then drive away.
Watch this.
Okay, sir.
Don't work, sir.
I'll surrender myself.
I'll...
Oh, shit.
Why are there so many cars?
I just bumped a man.
Okay.
And then I just do this.
Oh, my God.
There's so many people actually chasing me now.
Wait, wait a minute.
This is a little bad.
Wait, that car?
And then all I do?
Noink.
My car now.
It's just that easy.
And then, yeah, there's another cop car here.
Watch this.
Oh, my God.
He got out.
Never mind.
Don't watch this.
I'm okay.
Did I get caught?
No!
It's $1,000.
Oh, that's fine.
That's fine.
That's $1,000 Hong Kong dollars.
500 US.
That's okay.
For like murder?
I'm fine with that.
I think it like brought me, I mean for like murder, that's fine.
That's pretty cheap.
That's fine.
You know?
That's such a s- yeah, that's such a slap on the wrist.
You know what?
I don't mind losing another thousand.
Hey, now that I know it's just a thousand dollars.
There we go.
All I'm saying is that the cop...
We gotta...
We gotta budget cut the cops.
That's all I'm saying.
Look, I did that in front of the police station.
I'm just sending a message.
And now that I know, it's just $1,000.
No consequences.
Alright.
Nice.
We made it.
I don't mind you fucking her.
It's one of the perks.
But she has to understand the consequences if she disappoints me.
Are we clear?
Of course.
What?
attached are you a man of your caliber you don't need to worry about that i hope not way come in have a drink you have a fuck some famous pussy way not yet vivian maybe one day it's a trip man let me tell you are you gonna bang vivian lou boards the size of a building and you tell yourself i'm going to her place you bend her over the table and and then you do it there's no other feeling like it yeah okay Speaking of stars,
I need to go pick up Vivian.
Let Wade do it.
You and I have more business to discuss.
How about it, Wade?
Think you can handle a smoking hot starlet for the day?
Sure.
You know, as long as Ricky doesn't think I'm moving in on his territory.
No, of course not.
Here, take my car.
You take good care of my little starlet.
Go ahead and fuck her if you want.
Just don't damage the goods.
Bro, in front of Rick, oh, Ricky was just like, please stop talking.
about my girlfriend like that.
Poor Ricky.
She's just like...
Bro, that's my girlfriend, bro.
You look so sad.
Mr. Broken Bottom.
Thank you for the Super Chat thinking, thank you.
I really, really dreamed about a picture of my dad going because he looked like the thing in a trench coat.
But then put your face on it and felt so real while I woke up.
I should make sure it wasn't.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
bro it's just like bro that's my girl all right let's pick her up and i guess hold hands in public don't know don't
worry i'll wear a glove i'm way ricky sent me didn't he tell you no i was expecting ricky everything okay everything is Is it wrong of me to want to see my boyfriend?
Why do I have to put up with this?
No, Vivi.
It's not wrong.
And you put up with it because Ricky loves you.
Wait, what is his boyfriend?
Bro, that's fucked.
I sit in front.
That's actually so fucked.
Wait, that's Lucy Lou?
What's your name again?
It's Wei.
Ricky talks about him a lot.
Oh, all nice things I'm sure.
And you're here to basically do whatever We want something like that.
What do you have in mind?
Hmm.
Do you have Steady hands at high speeds?
Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, I can provide references if you like.
I'll have to wear gloves, though.
If we're talking about holding hands.
If we're gonna be holding hands, I have to wear gloves.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, I'm mad.
So what's the deal, Wei?
You a gangster like Ricky?
He's not a gangster.
Don't say that.
Let's say I'm as much of a gangster as Ricky.
That's too bad recently.
I've wanted to date a gangster.
Well, maybe I'll see if I can find one for you That would be nice.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
It's okay.
She's just her.
It's okay It's when he's just her.
We're in Hong Kong hospital fields are not that bad Sonny that guy's a creep and a fervor It's him what what do you do nothing, but he tried oh a party on Wallace Jones yacht Oh, I was like 16.
I got so high.
That's him.
Pull up.
Hi, Alex.
How are you?
Huh.
This is your new boyfriend.
Not yet.
Why?
Are you jealous?
Okay, I need to know a man.
I need to see your ID because I...
How long were you... How long was it when you were 16?
I'll let you take the girls home.
I'm not sure.
much that's worth now i'm a little concerned we raised for the girls and a hundred thousand sure i'll take your money too i'm raising with the girls in your car the extra weight will slow you down idiot we're gonna race with our girls they're dead weight function
this is gonna be great all right all right all right vivian i won't talk okay I did not expect to have the girls okay I this car is like this is not a racing car this is like an actual okay you wanted this you women wanted this this literally like a go-to-work car it's my nine to five car this is not a race car
There's like my Toyota That take to work
Alright, there's a shortcut That's fine That's just a little bit It is now
Okay, this is not Racing Song, though I have to admit That's fine, I can This is anti-pop Oh, there we go Oh shit!
Oh shit, they barricaded.
Just like destroyed it pretty bad, you know?
It could be really bad.
Doesn't mean it is.
Holy shit!
I didn't steal that car.
I should be racing with my police car.
It's okay, I still have two more stars.
I still have two more stars.
Oh my god, the police might actually win the race.
I didn't wonder if they were the ones that claimed the prize.
Oh wait, he's gone.
He just disappeared.
I think it's because the game didn't want the police.
this car to win.
He actually despawned him.
Oh my god, my heart is beating so fast.
Steady hands.
Gotta give you that.
Thanks.
I'll get a room, you two.
Shit.
The police.
Yeah, no shit.
You were there.
Okay, my car.
Yoink.
Oh, wait.
We're...
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
That's...
I have to use my Toyota.
Give me a sec.
All right, lose the cops.
I got this.
Don't worry.
Are they?
I wonder.
Don't worry.
Sweetie, you're rich and famous.
You won't get arrested.
Don't worry.
I almost left the girls.
silly thing silly girl you're beautiful rich and famous you really oh my god I'm in someone's place oh my god wait I'm literally in like someone's house right now
I always had to go this way earlier I actually drove to someone's mansion
why are you crying you wanted this I'm just giving you girls what you want Don't be pussies now Okay, go to Sandra's condo Nice work way That's fine Of course Well, unless Sandra has some other exciting plan I'm all excited out But you can take me for a drive And tell us Oh It's not my seventh girlfriend That's a bit later.
Oh, you are a confident guy, but I'm promising nothing.
You take me race.
Oh, that's it.
Just over there.
All right, I got you.
Oh my God.
And you have a shrine nearby too?
Do you think Ricky's gonna be mad at me?
That is a fun way.
Thanks.
Anytime.
Girlfriend plus one.
Ricky won't be mad.
He'll understand.
The car looks just as new.
Yeah, I got that.
Thanks.
Thanks for taking us out today.
It was my pleasure.
I swear, Ricky, it was like this one and you gave me your car.
Yay!
HK, wait.
Have I not been getting triad experience?
Okay.
Wait a minute What Oh
Because do you think they know I'm a cop guys Do you think Do you think they know I'm a cop chat Oh I got Kennedy town apartment Oh my god moving up in the world It can't be No way No way No Oh, my cover can't be blown.
There's no way.
There's no fucking way.
I'm gonna call Sandra.
It's way.
I'm feeling really stressed out.
It's the next day.
I'm sorry.
Did you want me to call you at like 12 a.m.
and be like, Do you love me?
So what do you think about dogs?
I'll be there soon.
Ciao.
All right.
I'll talk to Sandra.
Alright, what should I wear on my fast and hot Sandra?
I'd be like, um, um, give me a, name me a, the top, top five, uh, the one of your top five dishes of all time at, like, three in the morning.
Where's my closet?
Where the fuck is my closet?
This, this apartment's too big.
I can't even find my closet.
Oh my god, where do I put my clothes in this fucking apartment?
oh wait i have a sauna okay i don't have a sauna can i take a shower i can just pee apparently where is my closet
oh my god it's in front of the door okay is that my laptop wait okay i was gonna say where the fuck is my p why am i using tv monitor for my pc i'm not getting i'm not getting above 60 frames that when we have input lag all right i know what to wear this is perfect okay wait oh my no i just
that's right it's okay this would be a this is a perfect second date outfit right here i think this is wait let's see how what the oh i can't shoot my gun in my apartment I can't believe
you're...
I can't believe...
I'm gonna use the...
Oh, I should test up the grenade, you're right.
Okay, they're having a very intense argument.
Clearly they have a lot of issues.
I think they should get divorced.
They're that dedicated to arguing.
Alright, I'll be right back.
I got P.
next scene numbers thank you for the super chat thank you thank you all i'm saying is like if this doesn't snap them out of their other argument this is not their first argument they have a lot bigger issues to deal with all right uh we gotta go to our first date our second date also this private property can you please leave why are you oh my god even the the tenant left the tenant left he's like please guys this is private property like this is literally just my house please leave my leave leave my apartment my house please did you just yell at me ma'am
please leave you are on you are on right you're on private property leave oh you don't want to piss me off that's it
what yeah not so tough now okay I really need my I need my car I don't do this I Tokyo.
Okay.
He's like, ended.
I can't win this argument.
You put me out of my misery.
I'm just like, what happened?
Where did my...
Wait, is that police station in front?
No, it's fine.
I'm Hong Kong police.
Alright.
I got a perfect...
date outfit too for my second date.
Oh my god, this is actually the perfect car.
Sandra's gonna think I'm so hot when I come in here with a red Ferrari.
Alright, another cop can handle that police job, that cop job.
I gotta go on my second date.
A perfect car and outfit.
Wow.
I'm getting so much better at driving, guys.
Look at this.
Oh, my God.
Wait, I'm actually gaming right now.
Oh, I can't be late.
I can't be late.
It's our second date.
Wait, where is she?
Oh, shit.
Where the fuck?
How do I get down there?
Wait, the road ended.
The road actually ended.
How the fuck do I get down there?
Oh, it's over here.
Oh, there it is.
Why did it cancel?
That's a Nissan GTR R35 joke.
Oh, so like a Ferrari.
Thank you for the super chat Abby, thank you, thank you Um, yeah Abby, thank you, the super chat Thank you, thank you You're dressed up as a kick driver, streamer Thank you, the super chat Thank you, thank you I know, I'm here for our date
Over here So, uh, where do you want to go?
I don't care As long as we get there fast Whoa!
Okay, she has no ass.
Where are you looking at?
It's so flat.
Come on.
Speed up a little.
It's like, way.
Like, it's a fucking card for it.
Like, way.
I have no idea who the fuck she was looking at.
Now we're going somewhere!
That's why he was looking.
He just...
Yeah!
Woo!
All right!
Yeah!
Faster!
Okay, look, this is not like the ideal road for this.
Yes!
I might have...
I may have...
I may have not picked the worst road to do this on.
Now let's go faster.
Thank God there's no cars here.
Okay, now there you go.
It's a straight ride.
It's faster than this, right?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, she's an adrenaline junkie.
Now we're going somewhere!
Hang on, I gotta check this.
I just gotta text with my dad.
I have to go meet him.
Can you drive me home?
Yeah, no problem girl.
Drop Sandra off her apartment.
Whoa!
Now things are getting spicy.
That drive like super far away from the apartment.
Where is her apartment anyway?
God, it's so far.
Okay.
It's so far.
All right, it's this way.
I know, right?
Bro, this was a 60-second date.
Oh my god.
Guys, we're moving so fast.
We're already meeting the dad.
You think he'll like me?
With what I'm wearing?
Whoops.
It's fine.
It's okay.
She likes that.
She's an adrenaline junkie, remember?
They call them 60 second way.
All right, we're almost home.
Don't worry, Sandra.
Don't worry.
We're almost there.
Jesus Christ, you live like in the middle of nowhere.
Oh yeah, no, I definitely chose the wrong road for this.
I chose so far away.
I'm almost there.
Oh,
wait, that's your house again.
I forgot her place.
I still need to get that shrine.
Oh.
Tell me, Wade.
Have you ever had sex in a...
Wow!
I grew up in California.
You're dancing!
well what about you is that your thing i don't know i don't like that it's much too cramped especially in the car like this bro what the fuck what was this big bro are you gonna blue bobby okay i don't need to get the door for me that bitch thanks for the ride that was very exciting i like exciting rides that oh my god she slapped her flat Hang on,
hold on.
Come over here.
You are such a bad, bad boy.
Alright.
Oh.
Because that...
Oh, okay.
Okay.
There's one thing I know for sure.
And that way is...
I think, guys...
I don't know, but I have a feeling.
feeling that way may or may not might not be actually no that way might not be a version I'm not totally sure yet but I have a feeling
it's a little suspicion that I have no way Wait,
can I break into your house?
No, I can't.
Alright, let's see.
What's our next one?
Bad luck.
I'm not too sure yet.
Oh, it's not...
Oh, wait, nice.
It's literally like...
Oh, I can take a cab right here.
No way Before marriage It's scandalous Am I near the rich cockfighting Which one was it?
It's here, right?
Oh, it's right here Wait, actually, can you take me over here?
Sir?
Sir, sir, sir, sir, sir Okay.
Should I take this car?
I forgot, I can afford it now.
It's literally right next to me.
I- I- it's time for the real game now I'm done with all these side quests I'm set ready to play the main storyline oh my god as long as I don't accidentally hit the green it's
time for the main game but can I go across here yeah I can all right
we I'm finally done with all the side quests I'm ready to play the I'm being game now.
Oh, wait.
Can I go the wrong way?
Where is it?
Is it here?
Where the fuck is it?
Why the fuck is...
Okay, this road is so confusing.
Okay, I have to go this way.
There's so many highways.
Exits and entrances.
I'm not going the right way.
Yeah, I am.
No way out.
Okay.
And then we turn this way.
With my PNG chickens.
Finally.
I fixed my credit score.
I can fight with the inbred roosters.
Alright.
I'm ready.
I'm going all the way.
in so thank you for the super chat thank you thank you okay i had to i'm sorry but i have to bet soon say like there's no there's no way he can fuck this up all right go in all in
it has to be soon say he's so purebred he has six he has six talents Oh wait, that's the regular math.
He has 10!
Let's go, Sun Tse!
You wrote the art of war!
You should know all about war!
You're literally him!
Yeah!
Let's go!
Oh my god, I'm fucking rich.
Let's go.
And we're gonna turn him into a PNG chicken now.
I have a hundred percent win-ray on cockfighting.
Oh wait, are they doing Tai Chi?
Oh shit, the old people are doing Tai Chi.
Let's go.
Can I join in?
Wait, where's my gun?
Wait,
let's go.
A hundred percent win-rate.
All right, let's go.
Let's go do that mission.
What was it?
Bad luck.
How could I have bad luck?
I feel like I'm winning right now.
I just came back.
I came back from my date with Sandra.
And then my after party was the cockfight.
That's a good day for me.
Not gonna lie.
Relax in the car with Sandra And won a cockfighting match I'm winning in life
Alright I gotta go Talk to whoever's over there But I can rest someone You janitor Janitor get over here You're under arrest!
That's a key, right?
Now off I go.
That's right.
So clean belly.
Alright, nice.
Oh, you may join me.
Careful some tea.
He's doing it.
Just thought about it.
He should have taught longer before.
Oh, he starts cleaning the street at night Too comfortable.
I hear that he is already planning to make it permanent should uncle Po not recover Big smiley will kill him before he'll let that happen.
Indeed so many backstabbing that would allow Lee to take over the Sun on ye himself That can't happen.
No, it cannot Tuchin must go Oh, she's two-faced as hell.
There's no way Tuchin looks so friendly.
He looks so jolly why would he step down to chin like the heroine so far he has managed to control his habit i don't think you can control heron heroin on the brink of an abyss there's no controlling that of his supply to improve and now you will give him a nudge damn wait i'm gonna force him to overdose how maybe that's why he's so jolly Yeah,
obsessed with feng shui.
Yeah, he cannot bear to have the slightest thing out of place for fear of the misfortune it will bring.
He's just micro-chosing, dokey.
Oh, I'm going to make him paranoid.
Oh, my, that's not good for heroin addicts, though.
Paranoia is a big no-no for them.
I just got to slip in more heroin.
I just want you to talk to me.
Hey, you broken noses, guy?
Mrs. Jank said you are going to get...
told me to tag along give you feng sui advice feng sui
that's true my mom was obsessed with feng sui she also believed in ghosts you know what i mean
bro i think you might need a new car this is okay this car fucking sucks oh we're back here we're in sanger's place Goodbye, Mr. Chow.
Have a nice day.
Ah, right on schedule.
Usually goes gambling at this time.
Toochin loses money fast.
We better hurry up.
Wait, you're not toochin?
We can't do that.
We'll find a way in.
Come on.
Okay.
Wait, I thought you were toochin.
Wait, who are you?
Who?
Oh, my, yeah, guys.
I...
I don't think he's rich, guys.
I have a feeling.
He's fortunate.
He's treated.
Hey, guys.
Thank you for the five-kilous ships.
Thank you.
Hello, your Uber delivery.
He's here.
Find a way inside.
Your Uber Eats is here.
Find a way inside it.
Okay, I'll go this way.
Fast.
Are you okay?
Wait, I...
Wait, watch.
Alright, try this again.
Alright, you got this, bro.
You got this.
I believe in you.
Whoa!
A real one.
All massages are real.
How dare you insult the ladies?
They're as real as any other massage therapist.
What?
How dare he?
They're real to me.
How's business?
To be honest, Tunga?
It ain't damn shitty.
Really?
Yeah, what happened?
They're gonna break from their morning squad game.
How come?
Yeah, something went wrong.
I don't really want to talk about it.
All right.
Suit yourself.
Bro, he just said that my massage, my massage therapist weren't real.
How dare he?
Can I just walk in?
No, I can't parkour in high enough.
How dare, they're real than me.
They work very hard.
What the hell do you think you're doing?
What?
The boss's dog got out.
We don't find it before he comes back.
Yeah.
We'll roll.
Oh, shit.
I haven't seen it.
Yeah, we're just here to find his dog.
He might be... Wait, where do I go?
Let me in here?
Oh, he's...
Okay, I just gotta follow him.
I gotta follow Three-chin.
Or Four-chin.
Wait here.
I'll open the gate from the inside.
From the inside?
Why is this over here, right?
It has to be.
There's a cop there.
Yeah.
He's guarding that very suspicious ledge.
in two chins new package you want to tell them you turned us away oh sorry sir carry on yeah i got deliberate at this specific part this was two chins request
and then i go from here oh wait from here parkour express he ordered the parkour experience for his package
I did it.
I opened it.
I don't think I needed to kick it, but okay.
Why can't I kick this door?
I think it's fine.
No one will know.
Man, if I were him, I spent my money There's no statue.
How do I do this?
Let me just move the stuff to make it seem like this ghost that don't like you.
What about those faces?
Good idea.
Maybe not just me.
How do I do this?
Oh, say.
Yeah, say.
Let me just let me try something else.
We're some pretty unoriginal ghosts.
Please!
Let me in!
You'll get there.
Why don't I just move the stuff?
Like, ever so slightly...
Okay, if I do one mess with the feng shui, that should, like, move the things.
Feng shui's all about placement.
I didn't even...
Okay.
I didn't even... I just walked over it.
These are some fucking weak-ass...
Some weak-ass fucking bases.
Oh, it doesn't count!
Wait!
It doesn't count by me!
Oh my god, if I push them over, it doesn't count.
That's crazy.
I think I smashed more than four.
There we go.
Now we just have one.
There it is.
He really buys into this hocus pocus shit.
You can't blame the guy.
To a chance, got more money than the priest.
Oh my god, it's like 20.
numbers.
There you go.
Oh, it's at 13.
It's 13.
Wait, what?
Excuse me.
Why didn't you insta-doc?
Oh, there we go.
That's so weird.
Oh, that was at 6.
Oh, my God.
Keep accidentally.
I keep turning it too fast.
There you go.
We're not tied
444 where the fuck's the clock oh there
Say say say sub say say Dean say sub say That's death death death Oh, that's true.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying
What does your crush have to do with moving a piano?
That's your back, not your fucking dick.
All right, nice.
Yeah.
It's everything, Doki.
Mr. Chow, is that you?
There's some rats.
What do we do?
Just hide.
Stay calm.
Am I taking cover?
Am I...
This is...
They don't know.
I took cover on the wrong side.
Thank God I didn't get caught.
Hmm.
What if I just peek out right now?
They leave the gated community.
Oh, we gotta hack it.
I know, right?
That sucks so much.
much why would people need security cameras not like they're getting robbed or anything it's so safe here all right five six five seven eight eight five five that's so unsplung sway of him yeah exactly
Oh, there's two chin.
Oh my god.
Yeah, Dragoon, that's just that's like me.
Dragoons, why didn't you stop me?
Dragoons, you could have stopped me.
all of this golly's for look at this how can you let this happen it's all gone to shit got to shit what do you want us to do boss get out get out I need to think to hire dragons why didn't you stop me from becoming the touches to see like guys
The tiny ass cart.
But get in.
Zero!
Right, it's Benny.
Thank you for the gift of membership.
Thank you.
One of these.
Yeah, okay, bad idea.
You're a strange guy, old salty crab.
Thanks.
That means a lot to me.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck is this area?
Okay, that's...
I bumped a bush.
How is that property damage?
I suppose two chin accident gain 20 pounds.
Thank you for the super chat, Nero.
Thank you, thank you.
Where I finally have triad experience.
I didn't even realize I played the entire game without triad upgrades.
All right.
grab that what's this oh mailing weapon boost that sounds good oh yeah grab all these upgrades oh my god I have not been oh I have three statues to return okay
nice why didn't dragon would stop you from doing this obviously very bad thing
He looks so healthy on life support.
Of course.
I don't understand
Conflicted I'll do a conflicted Lord.
What is this?
Show what you tanks toy?
What is that?
What's this?
I'm curious What is this?
What does he want to show me?
there yeah i feel tech for the sun on yee i'm trying out a new tracking device can you give me a hand what do you need i put the tracker on a test package i need you to see if you can follow it as it flows out what in the sewers yeah if it worked we can move drug and guns this way in the sewers that will get you arrested you just drop in wherever you are and pick it up where you need it get into oh wait they warned me about people like you.
Are you sure?
Okay.
Can I see your license?
That's what they all say.
Do I want to get into a white van with a quote-unquote doctor?
Follow and stay close to a tracking beacon.
Is that the... Oh.
Bum, bum, bum, bum.
Where the fuck is it going?
Oh my god, there's a cop here Don't worry, I'm following traffic laws Sir Oh, there's like a Is there a small time?
I can't even tell It's just Glow's green
I mean, there's no cops here
Oh my I went this way
Oh shit, oh shit, oh shit.
He doesn't it's okay.
It's just a little property damage.
It's okay Oh my god, it's so far now Wait, where did it go?
Oh, it's that way That's fine.
We're doing okay yeah i was gonna say why is it flowing uphill
okay so now now it's oh it's this fountain made of sewage
guys i don't think i don't think you should dig dig the pennies are just actually drenched in sewage wait a minute Play on these types of fountains too?
And to run around with the...
with the water?
Hello, Dr. Tang.
The transmitter stopped moving.
Excellent.
Thanks, Wei.
This show our attack could really work.
Alright.
Hey, I got a free van.
Yay!
Throw itself it.
Yay, free van!
I should really repaint this van.
Conflicted loyalties.
All right, we'll go this way.
Yay, free white band.
What I've always wanted.
How far is this?
It's pretty far.
Let's grab a cab.
Bum, bum, bum, bum.
All right, we're not going to find...
We might not be there to find a cab.
Yeah, they're spinning some bars right now.
Oh, my God.
Next week?
Apparently, the Daffbug concert is next week on Fortnite.
So you know what we're doing on the 27th.
Fuck it up, Chinese boy.
Oh, he female.
You mean the movie star?
Oh, he female?
What's she doing these days?
She's doing another movie in the stripper assassin franchise.
A stripper assassin franchise.
That would be huge for Vivian.
yeah would help her profile yeah and the stripper assassin we're releasing the track that king produced tonight you have time you and the hottest star in hong kong go have fun i'd watch that the biggest franchise good we've got a joint venture making produced by steven chow i bring the production and distribution that's good money i bet yeah if vivian pisses me off that's where to end up But if there's more money,
if I keep her a star, I just have to make sure she doesn't flake out on me.
Um, the strippers, I can't, I got it.
Yeah, they have a, they have several spinoffs in the stripper assassin universe.
There's the, the stripper, um, the stripper zombies are.
There's a one where, um, it sets 50 years before the stripper assassin organization was built.
Okay, well, let's just...
Let's just grab the red car.
I don't feel comfortable driving that white van anymore.
Oh, yeah, don't forget the one.
Oh, my God.
You're right.
The one set in the year 3000.
We're stripping assassins.
We're outlawed.
And the descendant of the OG stripper assassin wants to bring it back.
Oh, the tournament arc was really good.
I agree.
Where every country nominates their own stripper assassin to represent them.
of who is the best stripper assassin.
What a masterpiece that one was.
I heard it out-earned the James Bond franchise.
I was not happy.
Oh yeah, I did not like the 2018 remake either.
I didn't like all the- I heard that they were stuck in production hell.
And there was like 10 rewrites of that script.
I think the craziest part is that I can't believe they casted Chris Pratt as uh as the stripper assassin like i get it they wanted to like subvert the tropes but like it just doesn't hit the thing you know like i didn't yeah when they like replaced it all with dudes i was like i didn't come here to watch to watch chris pratt be a stripper assassin i feel like they should i feel like they could show cast in chad and tatum exactly he he already got the stripping part down?
He's just needed, and like technically 21 Jump Street was sort of like an assassin movie.
He would have been perfect for the role.
A second thought gave the bitch the full treatment.
Hacker computer bugged the place and planned the cameras.
All right, Sonny, I'll go do that.
Excuse me, sir.
I don't think I've seen you before.
I'm a location scout.
Could you let me have a look around?
Only residents and their guests are allowed, sir.
I'll be quick.
I'll make it I'm the stripper assassin that they hide that they hide oh no I have to find another entrance
all right yeah when Netflix bought the adaptation rights it just wasn't the same that they had to go back to their roots you know
and then like the fact that they started using CGI more when they started stripping I was like made her watch the practical effects, you know?
You can tell that that pole was CGI.
It just didn't feel right.
Yeah, I know.
Like, what the hell?
Like, her leg face through the pole.
Like, you think I didn't notice?
CGI ruined the the stripping industry I get out of here he was just taking a smoking break and I just I'm like this random thug that beat him up I gotta get up there
okay all right this way enter the apartment oh wait we gotta do this first last time I listen to you on speakers.
My brother just walked in and asked, what the fuck?
How could, how does your brother not know about the stripper assassin lore?
The stripper assassin franchise.
It got nominated for an Emmy for a best screenplay.
God, your brother has no taste.
Where do I get in?
Oh, here, there's a door.
I was going to break the window.
Oh, shit, and that is my nail.
I should really hand in these statues.
Hey, your brother missed out.
Alright.
One is correct.
Four, five, six.
Oh.
Six.
Five.
Okay, we gotta figure out this then.
Seven.
Alright, seven, one, six, five.
wants to talk to you at the central rendezvous tonight all right bug the kitchen all right let me bug the kitchen first before we do the other cop stuff let me do the legal things first before we do the legal things
oh there you go
all right guys i got it oh timer oh my god forgot what's time
that's not calibrating oh i had to do i i forgot the other one
no your kitchen is not getting bugged okay i gotta hide it's fine they'll they won't know you look beyond beautiful tonight every time i looked at you stripper assassin remake but well thank you for the super chat thank you thank you yeah the kick start we're gonna make a fan project the kickstarter but to reboot stripper assassin and make it and give what the fans what they want you know i like that okay but let me go freshen up first whatever you want baby i'm gonna go have a smoke oh it's ricky plan a camera in the bed Don't worry,
they won't know.
That...
How would they know?
The grassroots reboot.
Where's the memory stick?
Oh.
It's all the way down there?
How the fuck?
Oh, she's in the kit shower.
I was gonna say, she's like right below me.
Oh, but she's in the shower.
Don't get spotted.
Runs.
Oh, get to the balcony.
Easy.
See, they never know.
Stealth.
And that's how you stealth, guys.
Get out.
All right, we gotta go.
Is that dead body?
What the fuck is that?
Actually, spawned.
Where are you looking at?
Huh?
That's right.
You're under arrest!
Oh, shit.
Wait.
Oh, that's awkward.
I don't remember how to let go.
Um...
I'm...
I gotta go now.
Goodbye.
It would be a good story to tell for her.
She'd be like, oh my god, girls, you guys wouldn't believe what just happened to me.
I just got grabbed.
It'll be a good story.
Tell her friends.
Oh, nice.
Parking lot.
Andrew, there you are.
Are you fucking crazy?
What the hell were you thinking wrestling Jackie?
Oh, I thought we were past all that.
I just wanted to congratulate you on that business with Tang.
Good riddance.
Now, what about Sunny Woe?
Anything new there?
What about Jackie, huh?
Fuck, Andrew.
Are you deaf?
No, Officer Shane.
I'm not.
but you clearly have forgotten who you're speaking to way forget about jackie a moment whatever we can get to stick to sunny woe will obviously hurt big smile lee and we both want that fine sunny had me put up a hidden camera in vivian lou's bedroom that means like the cops could access it too because we used cop stuff did have a reputation for that sort of thing think you could get a copy of that are you fucking kidding me She's got nothing to do with this shit.
This could be the piece that we're missing on Sonny.
Can you get it?
All right.
But I want Jackie in return.
Cut him loose.
Very well.
Get me the video and he walks.
I'll get it.
Yard of the deal.
Get me that video.
I just put the video.
Wouldn't I still have the USB on me?
I literally...
I don't understand.
Like, I use cop technology to...
to bug to bug the room so shouldn't the hkp like i'm that's what i'm using a cop app so shouldn't like shouldn't they already have access to it yeah
they don't check my logs they want to respect my privacy dokey they're just trying to respect your privacy don't check your your stuff because i'm just thinking i'm like bro i used I use like, like, I use like police technology to hack it.
So shouldn't they be able to access it?
It's like police property.
I'm literally using my HKPD app.
Just access my app.
I was accessed.
Sorry.
Sorry, I used the wrong, I was on my crime account.
That's why.
I was on the undercover cop account.
Josh, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I hardly got Kojima to make the stripper assassin game.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Alright, how do I get there?
Whoops.
Got a loss.
What?
Oh, it's my house.
I have to look at my...
I'm gonna look at my laptop.
Alright, here you go.
All
right, Pinchu.
I hope you're happy.
Yeah, I'm using NordVPN.
The cops will never get me.
What are you doing here?
Whoa.
Sonny says you've been really helpful to him.
And to me.
And I just wanted to thank you.
Oh?
Whoa!
Vivian, no.
Wait, wait.
What's this about?
Nothing.
I just...
Whoa!
I didn't consent.
Sonny's gonna kill me.
You gotta learn about consent.
Vivian don't you know that know what I just I can't do it anymore so you will just so you'll just have oh she doesn't want to cheat on Ricky anymore look Vivian you don't need to not with me okay so so you don't want to you mean okay like she's like um excuse me she's like you don't want to bang me thanks way whoa okay i was gonna say if she kisses him on the lips like what's the point she's like i don't understand
yeah only got 500 for that i i broke into a movie star's house and i get five hundred dollars That's like...
That's like...
I get 100 bucks.
I just...
What?
Are we waiting at Central Mall?
What a cheapskate.
Sonny's a goddamn cheapskate.
Wait, did you bring the video?
And Jackie?
Done.
This should be all I need to put Sonny Wo away for a long time.
And with Uncle Po dead?
Wait, how'd you hear about that?
Good news.
Travels fast.
I'll have Raymond yeah he's a dirty cop congratulations way what are you saying huh I'm saying it's over you've done your job it's time to come in it's not over not yet way the Sun on ye is serious the cop paid me 500 HKD I must admit I thought you'd be happy big smiley will take over it'll be even worse than it was under Po I can't come in now I'm not finished yet I understand your personal reasons for doing this your history with the Sun on ye this is why I selected you but you've done more than enough those are my orders fuck your orders and fuck you too Penju I came on to take down the Sun on you not to shuffle the deck Shen you're making a mistake it's cuz he wants to put someone in there that has a connection with him so that they so that the cops can have like so that he has like an inside man that works for him I'm pretty sure yeah so that he he wants to take that person down so he can have his own person in there I bet that's a dirty cop shit
oh is this a new crib no that's my old crib what do you want your friend Jackie has agreed he'll be walking out of Joe in a few minutes just thought you might want to be there to pick him up Thanks.
Yeah, they want someone they can control.
So they can have, like, exchange, like, information and deals and stuff.
They look the other way if they work for him.
That's some fucking corrupt shit right there.
Wait, guys, how much do I actually have left?
This feels like I'm almost close to endgame.
close to finishing the game
like five missions yeah this looks like end game because like the Pedro is literally like you're off the case it's over now the case is over and this is the point where I was like bullshit it's over let's turn in the statues it feels like I'm near end game okay let's alright alright Drug bus,
Steam Sajor.
Man, there's so many drug buss out there.
I feel like they should find a cop to handle that.
Yeah, we're done when I say we're done.
Where's my car?
Oh, there you go.
All right, we gotta turn in the statues.
We have so many.
Can I make...
Oh, I was gonna say, can I go on dates yet?
No, we're not cops.
We're cops, but we're undercover.
Alright, let's go turn in this.
Wait, actually, how far is it?
Oh, my God, it's so far.
We gotta get a cab.
I'm gonna get that green cab.
Hello!
I don't want to drive.
Alright.
Nice.
I gotta take an Uber, guys.
Thank you for the Uber.
four stars so that I'm gonna give you four stars so it'll motivate you to work harder for a fifth star I found one of your statue your horse good work way how you doing I'm fine with the past I mean your past I'll give him something to aim for is okay I kill but someone should ask it even if you ask it of yourself what are you a Zen master now of course Did you know then he'll know he has something to work for it guys All right,
that's an oh I have to unlock everything to get the super kick All right, let's grab do we even have one two three four?
Okay, that means I'm missing two more
All right X X oh X X X X The hardest combo in the world
what a hard combo guys oh my god all right so i'm gonna speed run this i don't need a i'm gonna speed run this because it'll take us forever you don't understand this will take us forever so we gotta speed run
there we go See, if I just did the combo, it would take us forever, guys.
You don't understand.
All right, get over here.
I have four more statues to do.
My favorite technique.
Yeah.
Charge me stun.
Wait, where am I?
Oh, I was going to save.
What the fuck happened?
I found one of your statues the ox you have done well.
Thank you for the statue It seems as though they're all finding their way back to me.
Yeah I did it destiny from the start.
What does that make me?
Oh, I've no doubt you'll return to Hong Kong Or affect many destinies Oh, yeah, I'm changing a lot of people's lives.
Surely that's why you came in the first place.
Maybe I just wanted to move back I'm the butterfly effect I decided to break my own rule and train a known triad for no reason whatsoever.
But I think we both know different.
Train a known triad.
What would you like to learn?
Uh, I should actually not do anything.
Okay.
Yeah, sure.
X, X, X, X.
Oh shit!
Wait, that's a cool ass move.
That's right.
You ain't having nanny kids.
For a long time.
That's right.
Get up!
No children for you!
Get up, man!
Get up!
Guys, I don't think like he's getting up, guys.
I don't think he wants to get up anymore.
There you go.
Alright.
Sad.
I gotta speed run this.
Get on that wall!
Boom!
That's five big booms.
Okay.
That's five.
This is faster.
This is a lot faster.
brain damage is faster than just kicking there you go see it's that easy it's my little speed run this is my speed run tech the wall poor wall it's my person it's my very own speed run tech that i figured out myself i found one of your statues the ball an important part of the collection you do in the states it makes you think i did anything different than what i'm doing now you have the feel of a man wait they give the super chat thank you thank you can commission doki plushie that when you squeeze the thing it does the doki laugh they give the super chat thank you that's a cute idea maybe maybe in the future it is a cute idea it's just more so like you I know that sound box is gonna die one day.
And it'll just sound like super fucking demonic.
And it's like when you get like an Elmo plushie and it's like, it's like it's calling for Satan.
Alright, it's time.
Speedrun tech.
Oh my god, the wall is...
Wait, the wall is...
It still has the aftermath juice.
There you go.
I can actually paint the wall as red.
Oh my god.
No, don't disobey me.
I'll paint the walls better, I swear.
Get over here.
The red walls.
There you go.
I'm an artist.
You're still recovering from your last visit.
All right.
One more.
I found one of your statues.
the rooster good good you don't look well it's good for feng shui exactly that's where i learned it what do you plan to do about it it is what it is so if your punches are weak that means no that that's ways to walk is it true that through practice and concentration you can change some problems are harder to solve than a weak punch sifu watch my students for a minute you may change your mind i think the students are going to be changing their mind sifu i don't know I don't think they're having a good time of what I'm doing.
Okay, one, two, three, four.
Spin and kick!
One, two, three, four.
Spin kick!
Alright, it's time.
I gotta spin that wall.
The side has too much white on it.
It looks very uneven.
I gotta make sure everything's painted nicely.
There we go.
It's looking better now.
Only abstinence!
Get over here.
I gotta make sure.
There we go.
Look at that.
Look at that wall.
That's a good ass wall now.
Got my roundhouse kick.
Alright.
What else?
We'll do one last thing.
Let us...
We'll do one last thing before we go.
I need a cab.
I'm too lazy to drive right now.
Oh!
Is that cab over there?
That's a cab over there.
We gotta do one last thing before we go.
Hello.
I think it's here?
Alright.
Nice.
Guys, I may or may not know where all the massage parlors are now.
I can look at the map and I'll know.
No.
I was like, yeah, I know there's a massage parlor right there.
All right.
That was a hard, we had a hard day at work.
We gotta relax.
I know that, I know that massage parlor is like the back of my head.
Might as well try everything once, right?
Yeah, this was my first time.
I may need to be disciplined.
Whoa!
Damn right.
I may just have to find a new job.
You know what they say about coming with the customers.
Wow, that's a new line.
That...
What do they say?
I don't...
Guys, I may have a problem.
used it so much that they the game has given me new voice lines the game has actually came i i i never heard that line before oh i might have wow i think maybe i might have been going to too many massage parlors i'm i think like i'm not even a regular customer anymore i literally just live there now the game is trying to tell me something i thought i heard it up next thing they give me the super chat thank you thank you wait does that mean she'll give me new i've unlocked a new voice lines if you go to the massage parlor x amount of times the game starts giving you new voice lines oh is it hot in here i can feel my temperature rising already
Guys, I just want to see what the other voice lines are.
They are generated for you.
Oh.
You'll come back anytime, okay?
Damn right, Owl, girl.
Blackfire, thank you for the five gift of ships.
Thank you, thank you.
I think this is the right time to call it now.
I think next part would be the finale, right?
I think it finished the game next week.
I was gonna play longer but since I only have five missions left we're just gonna stop here because I think I can actually finish this game next week um I don't want to overdo it because I I need to rest my voice now but I had a great time I had a great time of course I had a great time of course you do jokie I'm so relaxed now I'm but I hope you guys had a fun time watching as always but before I go um I just want to do a little shilling before I go but you guys didn't know I do have and right let me average let me show this right next to the massage parlor uh call now look at the massage um but uh I want to do a little shilling oh what oh no I can't tab out I want to oh my god it won't Let me tab out.
No!
My massage fighter!
Okay.
Wait.
I gotta have a perfect angle for this.
And then...
We're gonna...
Alright.
Oh my god.
The game.
It knows what I want.
But, there's less than four days left on the Gina.
The Gina draws X Go Keeper, a pair of collab.
So you can see a pen on let me see if i can grab the pictures um but if you click on the link if you click on the link in the pin in the chat uh you can pre-order any of these items in the collection there's less than four days left and after after the end of pre-order it's gone forever i think i'm not that sure but But,
um, you should grab them now before, if, unless it, in case it is gone forever.
I'm really good at this.
The shillies.
Oh yeah.
Um, you can grab any of these items.
Um, you can order individually or as a part of the collection or the full bundle.
The bundle does come with extra stuff in it, like the, the snapshots, the voice, um, the voice pack and other, like, charms and stuff.
But you can also get the individual items.
So you want to have some dad trip or some dragon wound trip.
This is the time to pre-order them.
Anyway, guys.
I'm going to head off now.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you still, for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
For stuff for next week.
Obviously, there's going to be like two silk song streams next week.
We're going to finish up Sleeping Dogs.
I do have a collab.
sponsor collab as well next week i have two sponsor streams i have two sponsor streams next week and uh two silk song wait two four i think that really just takes up my entire week then i guess yeah that's basically my entire schedule when i think about it um um but yeah i think uh i think that's my schedule for next week silk song finishing sleeping dogs two sponsor streams one is a sponsored collab stream and that's basically it so i hope you guys enjoy You know it's,
oh my gosh You know what it's like It's so hard to To like Not start new game series Because so many games Are coming out Like In the next couple of months Like in the next couple of weeks There's so many like Really good games Like Hades 2 Is finally coming out of beta Like the full game is finally coming out Next week And then there's There's just so many games It's so hard start a new game series because I know I have like other I have to finish my current stuff before I go into something new but anyway guys I'm gonna head off now uh my voice you can tell that my voice has already started dying so it's time to rest a bit uh but anyway guys we have a fun time watching I always appreciate you guys watching me and I hope you always have fun watching me and you guys always give me so much energy um I'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye